so my talk is on finding case simple
parts and cycles in a graph directed
edge weighted graph and this is joint
work with my student with another wall
okay so finding cape shortest paths from
s to t one can think of three different
variants of this problem and we are
staying with a graph a directed graph
with non-negative edge weights and
you're given a pair of vertices s and T
and the goal is to find K shortest paths
from s to T and we can define three
different versions of this problem and
we are going to concentrate on the last
one so the first version is well find
the K shortest paths from s to T which
means that you find the shortest path
and then K minus one additional paths
that are shortest you know after
removing the parts that were found
before then before the before this part
and the point is that here you are
allowed to have cycles in the path and
if you do this then if you allow this
then this problem is easy and there's an
algorithm by epsilon that works you know
for K paths
it's basically Dijkstra plus K the
second version of the problem is to say
find the K shortest paths but they
should all have distinct edge weights so
if you have multiple shortest paths with
the same weight then they don't count
you just output one path with each shall
wait now this turns out to be really
hard in the sense that it's np-hard even
for K equals two and the problem that I
will be looking at is the third one
which is intermediate and complexity and
this is a well studied problem I find
case simple paths from s to T so you
don't allow cycles and in fact the paper
by UPS trained clips that this version
the version I'm going to look at is in
fact more common in practice than the
one that he looked at so even though
this is not that well-known in the
theory in literature it's actually quite
a common problem and for this problem
there's an
than a classical algorithm by yen that
runs in k times o tilde of K times M n
time again we'll always be using M as
the number of edges and n as the number
of vertices and there's been have been
small improvements since then but it
remains an autoloader MN and and there's
a reason for that because Williams and
Williams it belongs to the class that is
hard for a PSP on the sub-q bukh
algorithms and so they established that
if the graph is dense so M equals N
squared yeah but but if you just run the
condition is that you fix SN T and you
want a sequence of K parts that are
shortest from s to T so of course they
may be they may be multiple but then
once if there's only one shortest path
from s to T then you have to generate
the next path which may have lengths
that's longer than the shortest path so
you just keep doing that you know making
overlap oh yeah they can oh they just
have to be they can't you can't output
two identical parts yes okay and then
delete every find the shortest path in
the remaining graph there's certainly
one algorithm to do it and in fact okay
so in the that's basically being the
technique in the past yes that the
problem that you are referring to so the
problem that Russell was mentioning is
well the way you would find the second
shortest path is to find the shortest
path then find a shortest path for each
edge on the path remove the edge and
find a shortest path in the graph and
then take the path of minimum weight
among these spots that by the way this
problem is called the replacement parts
problem and be talking about this like
midway through my talk but thank you for
pointing that out okay and in fact all
of the previous methods in fact work
that way and by the way I'm looking at
the all pairs version of this problem
you know I'm going to present a
different method of finding it so that's
in fact the algorithm maker so is that
clear now so that's yeah so and that
turns out to be a lot more challenging
than just finding for the case of
shortest paths without requiring them to
be simple you can essentially do
something like that star but I mean you
have to be a little bit more Epson has
that yeah the first one will or you know
you can always get the first path to be
simple but successive shortest paths
you're requiring them to be simple I
mean okay so let me take good so you
have s and T so this is the shortest
path and it may turn out that the the
shortest way to get to s to eat a second
time is to take two edges in here then
go back to s and then come in this way
this is shorter than any other path that
goes to T without having a cycle okay so
the first version of the problem the
easy version of the problem doesn't care
of cycles are performed so it it could
generate paths like this by free meaning
that each successive path the only
requirement for your kate part is that
it be shortest such that it doesn't
exactly coincide with any any of the
paths generated earlier depending on the
edge weights you know so it may turn out
that all edge all paths
but you have no control over the weights
its you're just given an arbitrary graph
and here it is a shortest path from s to
T and if you look at my third version of
the problem and consider maybe there's
just one other path that goes from s to
T without actually creating a cycle and
that has a very expensive edge on it
well there are plenty of paths that by
looking at two of them and then the
third one goes like this and then goes
like this and that's a lot more cheaper
than you know going doesn't have to go
back to s it can go to something that's
sorry it doesn't have to go back to s I
am into this because I have an example
later on where I do go back to s but in
general any cycle is not allowed so you
may have another I mean yeah yes so you
could have something like this and then
just goes in like this and then goes
like that and you know but and you know
K can be arbitrary so if you allow paths
like this then you know you can roughly
call it Dijkstra like techniques can
allow you to generate successive paths
very efficiently while if you insist
that each successive path is simple
I mean the best known algorithm is tilde
MN for constant K and Williams and
Williams have even shown that for dense
graphs it's equivalent to a PSB so it is
a hard problem and of course for K
equals one all three problems are asking
for exactly the same thing short to spot
and you know it always is a shortest
path that's simpler so the problem that
we are looking at and they are looking
at a collection of problems related to
finding K simple shortest paths and case
and put shorter cycles in a graph and
the prior work as I said there's been
quite a bit of work on case simple
shortest paths from s to T and I'm going
to be using acronyms K s is B instead of
K because that shortest path to the SP
simple shortest paths KS is B and the N
and then some refinements to you know
within the Hotel de by Buckley for
Loewenstein and Rho DT and Zwick what a
different method and then there is I'm
also going to look at case and push or
the cycles and for shortest cycles the
only prior word that we are aware office
just enumerating case simple cycles in
the overall graph and in no particular
order you're not asking for non
decreasing order of weight or length and
this is again a classical problem just
like the case is P in the 70s there was
a lot of work in this problem and the
first polynomial time algorithm was
given by Carson in 73 and that was then
improved to linear time by Johnson in 75
so kind of solved but only in no
particular order so the variants that we
study are the following so okay we
consider the Esaias p problem for all
pairs and I should mention that well
I'll talk in the next slide maybe we
don't have a full answer but we do have
some interesting improvements and MIT
method is interesting it's quite
different from prior methods and then we
go to the cycles version and it consider
both variants
find the case simple shortest cycles to
expect through a specified vertex that
corresponds to KS is P with just a
simple shortest path from a given vertex
to a given vertex and the overall graph
version is what we call K all vertices
simple cycles so for every vertex in the
graph find the K shortest simple cycles
ok so we consider those two versions and
then corresponding to enumeration we
have two more problems we study it is
enumerate the case simple shortest
cycles
K all simple cycles and a case simple
shortest paths K all simple paths okay
and so what are our main contributions
of course we did a systematic study of
all of these different variants but we
also found new algorithms to address
this this this property four paths
through
technique we call path extensions and
with this technique we saw two ApS is B
that is SSP for all paths in this same
Oh till that time as for a single pair
so for a single pair it was Hotel de kmn
and so it will be Odell de MN for to a
PSI SB and we had the hardness result
from Williams and Williams and we match
that same result for the all pairs
version for all theta of N squared
versions and with this new technique
that we call path extensions and the
same technique gives an improved
algorithm for three ApS si speed but
it's a factor of M slower but that's
still better than what's the best known
which is you know basically running the
SIS P algorithm and squared times so
that's like mno2 diamine cubed
unfortunately our current algorithm
doesn't scale to larger k and that's an
interesting open question then we use
path extensions in a different way to
come up with a very efficient algorithm
for enumeration of simple shortest paths
so we solve K all s is P that is
generating simple paths in the graph in
non decreasing order of weight where we
spend all em time for the first path and
that's inevitable because the first the
shortest path in the graph is just an
edge of minimum weight and clearly you
need to spend em time to find the edge
of minimum weight but thereafter we just
spend or tilde of J comma n time for the
J spot so essentially for the in if K is
a constant then each additional path is
found in off log n time so it's very
efficient and it uses path extensions
but a different path extension method
from what we used in for the first
problem so those are our algorithmic up
and those are ya know non-trivial
algorithms and then we give several
reductions to obtain Hotel de MN time
algorithms for the remaining problem so
we consider six problems of which for
one AK s is B KS is P there are already
algorithms at IO tilde and there were
two more that were addressed
algorithms in here so that leaves three
other problems the cycles problem for
all three versions and we give for que
si si so simple shortest cycles and K
all generating all simple cycles in non
decreasing order of weight we give o
tilde MN time so this problem is where
there was prior work for the case when
you didn't care about the ordering you
just wanted to generate simple cycles
that you could do in linear time but
here we spend o tilde MN time but we
still have a reasonably efficient
algorithm and similar to all pair simple
shortest paths for all all vertices
simple cycles for two abs is a we have
an efficient algorithm it degrades
slightly not as bad as what we have up
here this becomes super MN for K greater
than two and finally he relevant to this
workshop we show hardness results and
our hardness results because they're
mainly interested in sparse graphs our
hardness results are with respect to
finding a minimum weight cycle in a
sparse graph now in other hard under the
for dense graphs this is known to be
equivalent to a PSP so n cubed but for
sparse graphs we can solve it in O of MN
time and you know it's a very well-known
problem I mean people have certainly
been trying to get better than all of MN
for it so we showed reductions from
minimum weight cycle for all our
problems except of course for K all s
ISP for which we actually have a very
efficient algorithm and we the
reductions we use we call them MN
reductions because you know it's going
to preserve the number of vertices and
the number of edges in the graph okay so
the hardness class just to reiterate so
the a PSP hardness class is very you
know well known and it's like a major
theme of this workshop by Williams and
Williams but the problem is that if you
are mainly interested in sparse graphs
you know which is often the case it does
not distinguish between dense and sparse
graphs so we just consider this
that preserves path sparsity starting
with minlid cycle and so let's call that
sparse m/min wait cycle hardness with
respect to sub m n algorithm so if you
could yeah if you could get a sub m m n
algorithm for any of our problems you
would get sub m and for been week cycle
which has been open for a long time and
I should also mention that you know
there are other ways of approaching n
cubed from sparsity too dense to dense
graphs and for example for min weight
triangle there's a very nice algorithm I
should have mentioned by it I and Rohde
which does it in oh of M to the three
halves time so that again becomes n
cubed for dense graphs and it's faster
than MN but it's not quite as big a
class MN there are lots of problems that
have or tilde graph problems that have
four tilde MN running care for sparse
graphs so anyway so that's not class
that's relevant for our problems MN is
the one that's relevant for our problems
okay this is the maybe I'll just hit the
highlights here so this is all of our
results and so four cycles at least four
cycles in non decreasing order of weight
there's nothing known before except as I
said for K all SISC if you didn't care
about the ordering there was there's a
very efficient algorithm linear time per
cycle so our new algorithmic result
which is which I think it's you know
kind of the most non-trivial part of our
contribution actually for just the case
of two ApS is P you can actually use
something called distance sensitivity
oracles that I will define a little
later in the talk and I'll use DSO for
short for that and using them you can do
it in or encode tilde and cube so it's
fine for dense graphs but again we want
efficiency for sparse graphs and we get
o tilde MN and with the new method for
this and building on bootstrapping on
that method we get om square em N
squared for three ApS ISP and that's
again a factor of an improvement over
previous results and there is a lower
bound here trivially both of these
problems are at least as hard as a PSP
because they include
the output includes the a PSP solution
so I didn't put that in there and then
when it comes to 2x is P so this is the
lower bound that Williams and Williams
scale for to SSB for under n cube
reductions and they use the reduction
from in weight rank triangles but we can
also that and that reduction in fact
works for sparse graphs so we do have
that mean way triangle reduces to s is P
but as I pointed out min weight triangle
actually has an M to the three-halves
algorithm so we give a different
reduction from min weight cycles to to
sis B and KS is P is the same and so
these are all new results so be sure
that KS is P is equivalent to KS is C so
all the results for KS is a translate to
ksi speedboat lower bounds and
algorithms and all of the remaining
problems except of course the last rule
which is for that efficient result they
run in ho tilde MN time for here again
this is the all vertices version so it's
a little analogous to a PS is P so the
two for K equals two it's a little
faster its tilde MN but then you go K
greater than two right now you can only
get km and square but we can stay at km
n squared we don't have to grow further
yeah and then for all s I see we have I
guess tight bounds relative to a
hardness assumption so we show that it
reduces to two all SISC and we can in
fact generate each successive path in
hotel diamond time ok so I won't talk I
mean these algorithms I'll talk about
some of the reductions for the
algorithms in here I mean they did a
quite a little bit of work but they are
not you know they're fairly
straightforward so I will concentrate on
some of our reductions and then talk
about our up about that algorithm with
the novel technique for abs is be okay
so amend reductions I mean these are
fairly strong reductions and they work
for our class of problems we could have
defined weaker reductions and still got
the desired result that you know in
provements below MN would imply
improvements for drum Minh weight cycle
but we just considered reductions where
we say if you have to graph graph
problems P and Q and MN reduction from P
to Q means that given an input to P with
ember to see M edges and n vertices we
can transform in linear time n plus 1
time this input into a graph G prime
which if we solve with an algorithm for
Q will in turn return a solution for P
in o of n plus n time so a very strong
reduction we can work with this
definition for all of our reductions and
our main reductions and the ones that I
will show you is min wait cycle reduces
to 2 s is P of course this is trivial
from 2 to K and also that KS is B is
equivalent to KS is C and and of course
the remaining hardness results are
pretty much trivial because it turns out
the left turns out to be a special case
of the right and also there are some
prior known results for instance I think
it's folklore that many wait cycle
reduces to a PSB and it was shown by got
leaf and loewenstein that to s is p
reduces to a PS p plus o of n square
processing so there is this reduction
and in fact you can yeah and then also
the the Tian's make sure that KS is p
reduces to k calls to to s is B we won't
be using any of things but just to point
out reductions that are known okay so
the showing the equivalence is very
simple so we'll just do it in both
directions so KS is P reduces to KS is C
we just create add a new vertex u prime
to the graph and put 0 weight edges from
u prime to s and T to u Prime and then
we see that the Kate's simple shortest
cycle in this updated graph G Prime
through u prime is precisely the kid
simple SD path from s to
and the reverse ksi SC reduces KS ISP it
was slightly different reduction they
have to go from cycle to path so the the
goal is to compute K simple shorter
cycles through V given vertex V M G so
we split V into VI and vo so all
incoming edges to we are made in coming
to VI all outgoing edges from we become
outgoing from vo
and then we can observe that a simple
cycle through B in G is transformed into
a simple path from vo to VI in G Prime
with the same same weight so we have the
reverse reduction KS I see reduces to KS
is B so the two problems are equivalent
okay so for min weight cycle reduces to
2 s is B we use this generic
transformation where to convert from g
to g prime where for every vertex v we
split it into VI and vo as we did for
the SI c reduction but we actually put
an edge from VI to vo of way to 0 and we
and then all incoming edges come become
incoming to vi and all outgoing edges
from we become outgoing from vo and we
do this for every vertex so the incoming
edges the other end point is coming out
of the over text for that but except for
see it's an Co and the outgoing edges go
to the i but X a sub I so we do this and
this is the graph G prime that we will
find you can see that because they put
weight 0 a simple cycle through vertex
any given vertex B and G is transformed
to a simple path from V o to VI in G
Prime with the same weight ok now we
need to add a little more few more
gadgets in order to complete the
transformation and I'll illustrate that
with an example here so this is a
reduction so in blue is a graph G Prime
and I've drawn it for 3 vertices so N
equals 3 here so you have and they're
numbered what vertices are numbered 1 2
3
you have the edge zero weight edge from
the eye vertex to the overt X then we
have a part and that's the part in here
on n plus 1 vertices all with zero
weight edges so that's p 0 to P 3
because N equals 3 and now we are going
to connect up this path to the vertices
in G prime so the so if we consider the
jate vertex in here J i2j oh there will
be an incoming edge to J Oh
from P I minus 1 so this is 2 O so it
comes from P 1 and there will be an
outgoing edge from J I to P I so those
are the green edges and now we assign
weights and they're going to assign
fairly large weights first let little W
be the maximum edge weight and G and
they're going to set capital W to be n
times little W and the purpose point of
this is to observe about capital W is
that W capital W is greater than the
weight of any simple shortest path in G
prime because the maximum weight on an
edge is little W and any simple path
contains at most n minus 1 edges
okay so then we observed that so what
would a the shortest path from s there
from so we are going to consider the
second simple shortest path problem from
p 0 to P 3 to s is P from p 0 to P 3 the
shortest path is of course the black
path because of weight 0 and any other
path is going to have to take a red edge
and a green edge because those are the
only edges going out of the part and
they are going to have very large weight
so the second shortest path will take
one of these edges out and then traverse
through the graph to get to the I vertex
some a vertex and then come back to the
path and then continue to the end and we
make another simple observation which is
that it would never be you never the
second simple shortest path will never
if it starts out of PJ it would never go
to a vertex that PJ plus 2 or greater or
and of course clearly it wouldn't go
back to a path vertex before PJ because
that would create a sight
that is the part we'll have to start
from PJ - one that's all we have it here
and then take a path through the graph
and then come back to PJ and that's
because if you sum up the weights of the
corresponding red edge and the green
edge so it's n minus J plus 1 W if you
went directly to the next vertex 2 + JW
so that gives you n plus 1 times W if
you went to the next took the green path
green edge to the vertex next to the
vertex from which you started out and we
went to any vertex green vertex green
edge vertex green edge to a vertex
beyond the next vertex you will add at
least one more capital W and that would
never be useful unless the graph has no
cycles at all or something because any
path through the graph has weight less
than W so the second simple shortest
path starts from some pj minus 1 goes in
here takes a path to the corresponding
ji and comes back and of course for it
to be shortest it has to take the
shortest simple path in G from that Jo
to that J I and that would be the
shortest simple second shortest simple
side the shutter simple cycle in the
original graph G which is what we needed
to show okay so and this is a linear
size reduction and doable in linear time
I mean oh this graph has all of M edges
and of n vertices and and so this is a
remand reduction okay so those are the
only two reductions I wanted to show I
just wanted to conclude this part of the
talk to just point out that you know o
tilde MN just for the pro type of
problems we've been considering it's
quite rich and also there are lots of
books there are lots of refinements
within this class so if you look at
unweighted we have Oh exactly MN form in
weight cycle and unweighted a PSP both
undirected and directed next you come to
weighted and then for the undirected
case we have an almost MN time algorithm
MN log alpha MN for undirected minimum
edge cycle and undirected weighted a TSP
now if you come to directed then
have many of the problems we considered
here and also directed a PSP with MN
plus N squared log log n and then the
next class is MN plus N squared log n
which is our algorithm for to a PS is P
for to AV of several of our algorithms
here have this type of bound and then
they so which I'm going to define very
soon this is the distance sensitivity
oracles they have an additional log
factor higher but they're still Hotel de
MN now the remaining problems we
considered hair still polynomial time
but a larger larger then little Omega of
M and till Otel diamond little Omega
tilde okay so so the rest of the talk
will cover the algorithm which as I said
use this path extensions that may not be
detours I will explain that why that's
interesting and talk and talk about the
our algorithmic contributions okay so
detour sir okay what is known as I said
previously the only problem that has
been studied this case is P and has been
studied a fair amount and all of the
known algorithms for KS is P say and now
we are considering KS is P from X to Y
compute D tools around each edge in the
graph so if you know it what is the
shortest but this is referring to what
Russell asked what is the shortest path
in the graph from X to Y if I remove a
particular edge along the path and you
find that power path for each edge along
the path and then take the minimum of
minimum weight edge among this
collection as the answer for 2's is P
and this can be actually extended for
any K and in fact what they are
computing in the process is what's
called replacement parts and that's
again a problem that's been very well
studied and it's what's only for K
equals two and here you ask you want to
have a table so that you can quickly
answer queries of the form what is the
shortest simple path from X to Y if a
particular edge of the path fails so you
have a
you know a table that has such an answer
for each edge and in along the spot and
all algorithms currently for 2's is P or
KS is be essentially compute replacement
parts and all replacement parts can
compute what's called a detour from the
shortest path and a detour is just you
take your shortest path and then you're
only allowed to create a new path by
exiting the current path and of course
you put exit right at X find a shortest
they find a path that avoids the path
this shutter spot and comes back at some
further point like B 3 here and then
continues along the path up to Y all
known algorithms for either KS ISP or
replacement parts have used this
strategy and in fact so much so that
this in fact even a lower bound
hershberger toy gave a lower bound m
square root of n lower bound for both
2's ISP and replacement parts in this
path weight comparison model assuming
that the algorithm only examines these
Lito so you know why would you need to
examine anything else you can show that
the second every year every replacement
path has to have this form so assuming
that this is the case then this is a
lower bound now turns out that our
algorithm for 2's ApS is P and engender
for K doesn't good generate and examine
paths that are not d2 so it actually
falls outside the framework of this
lower bound and any of these previous
methods to solve that as is B okay so
one more slide on replacement parts I
said replacement parts are very well
studied and closely related to K 2 s is
be you know pretty much the same for
known algorithms and send a cost is you
would take an algorithm for replacement
parts and spend linear time a time
proportional to the length of the path
to select the minimum weight replacement
parts now you can ask about all pairs
replacement parts now this has been
studied before bite a bit even though
all pairs K simple shortest paths hasn't
been as far as we know hasn't been
studied before now the problem here is
that if we try to do the same strategy
as up
here we notice that the output would
potentially have size and cubed because
for every pair XY we have to have an
output for every edge on the shortest
path the replacement path for it so
that's pretty large so what has been
done for replacement parts for the old
paths case is to instead construct
what's called distance sensitivity
oracles and this is the DSO a compact
table of size o tilde N squared that
from which any specific you could query
that table and in constant time and what
they say you know what about the
starting from X ending to Y but avoiding
this particular edge a B then this in
constant time you can query the table
and get the answer to this so this was
the first deer so was constructed by
Dmitri scary at all but the current best
bound for DSO is again o tilde MN but it
has an additional logarithmic factor
over the other problems but still it
runs pretty fast unfortunately to get
now ap to ApS si SP from this deer so
takes n cubed time for the same reason
that we have this n cubed because we
have to find the minimum path among all
of the possible replacement paths I mean
for it for all pairs so so for dense
graphs this is still good but for sparse
graphs and cubed is too much so this is
where our method comes in so what we do
is we have a two-phase approach we first
compute what we were collection of sets
called nearly sis BK k nearly Esaias
business now what we want to find out
the exact K is B sets for every pair XY
we define this quantity K nearly s is B
sets and then we give a general
algorithm compute a P a very efficient
algorithm that if you have that nearly
sis B sets you can actually compute the
exact answer pretty efficiently in KN
squared plus N squared log in time ok so
I will go ahead I'll define the qk sets
first for q2 and then then for
the general candidates yeah so here's
the definition of the set given a pair
of vertices X Y Q 2 X Y contains a
shortest path from X to Y and then the
second part in Q 2 is going to be the
shortest path from X to Y or shortest
path from X to Y that avoids the first
edge xB okay so for example in this
problem in this graph let's say the two
the exact output we want so assume all
edges awaited 1 so we have two paths
shortest paths both with three edges so
the exact answer you want are the paths
X BA D Y and X B CY however Q 2 is
asking for well you take one of these
two paths let's say it takes X B D Y the
second path has to avoid the edge X B so
it will have it as a second part xfg dy
okay now if it happened that the two
shortest paths already started with two
different edges the Q 2 will be the same
as the exact output we want okay
so the point about this the Q 2 sets is
that they can be computed pretty
efficiently with DSO because each second
path for a given pair X Y the second
part can be obtained with a query to DSO
saying give me the shortest path from X
to Y that avoids this edge on the
shortest path first stage on the
shortest path so now we can in fact the
the previous bottleneck that we had that
it took and cube to just find query the
DSO no longer holds at least the Q 2
sets can be found in awe of N squared
time plus the time for DSO and and in
fact there are even faster ways of
computing this which I won't go into to
compute the Q 2 sets for K equals 2 but
this is good enough DSO is good enough
so all that remains is to come so we can
compute the first path in the pew two
sets with a single a PSP algorithm and
the second path using their source
constant number of queries for each pair
and all that remains is to compute to a
PSP from the Q two sets and for which I
will show you this algorithm
that does it with path extensions and
more generally the Q key sets
generalizes the q2 sets and let me just
introduce this notation so we will use P
star K X Y as the actual output we want
the case simple shortest paths from X to
Y and G and QK is just going to be if
the K minus one shortest paths in this
set all start with the same edge then
the the next path would be the shortest
path from X to Y that avoids that common
edge so there's the edge XA if it
happens that the K minus one shortest
paths from X to Y all share the same
first edge then you'll kick cable not it
will always have the next path the Cate
path as a path that avoids the edge XA
so it's a natural generalization of the
queue to case maybe in suggesting the
shortest path and the second shortest
path look at the first K minus part one
paths and only if they all share the
same first edge would qk x y potentially
be different because it has to use a
different first stage and so now with
this if suppose we have somehow computed
the qk x Y sets and we know we can do it
for q2 the task for algorithm compute
the ApS ISP is very very very you know
specific it says you already have a Q K
X Y you just examine it and check are
the K minus 1 shortest paths in it all
starting with the same hedge XA and if
it is then somehow determine if the kid
simple shorter spot also starts with a
jacksie because if not QK already has it
it has the shortest edge outside of the
edges that start with the edge XA so
that looks manageable and in fact we
show that it is manageable and for any K
I mean here this works for any K very
efficiently in K N squared plus n square
n log n time so this is again the same
observation and the way we find this
gate path when needed is with this
following fairly simple observation
which is that if all paths and P XY
start with the same first edge XA
that's the case that we have to kind of
address then if you know go so this was
a common first stage then they all end
at vertex a so if I now go to P star K
of a why so there are K short simple
shorter spots from a to why it must
consist of the right sub parts of the
paths in P star XY that is removing edge
ax a so let me just explain that so what
this is saying is suppose they have the
case let's say K is equal to 3 and I
consider the the 3 shortest paths from
simple shortest paths from X to Y and
they all start with the same first stage
X a so they look like this dilemma is
saying then it must be the case that in
P star a Y well at least the widths of
the K 3 shortest paths from air 8 y must
be equal to the widths in here and I
mean they are really this and I'm just
saying it that way in case you had
multiple shortest paths with the same
weight and then you chose one and you
know this is showing something else so
this may look trivial and maybe this
addresses some questions that were asked
in the beginning but and it's true of
course for this lemma but just observe
that need not be true in general because
if I look at the three shortest paths on
a to Y it might be the case that say
this red path actually used X in order
to go to Y that was the best way of the
cheapest way to go to Y was to go
through X then that's no longer then
it's no longer the case that this lemma
holds okay so in general this would
happen and this is really what
complicates the algorithms for simple
shortest paths are supposed to just the
version where cycles are allowed but of
course we can see that in the case of
this lemma the premise of this lemma
this cannot happen because if this
happened then it means that this portion
of the path from X to Y it cannot use
edge XA because that will create a cycle
it uses some other edge going out of a X
and this portion of the path is a path
from X to Y and it has wait no more than
this red path and and you know so for
the purposes of our algorithm
it would already be in the qk set okay
so either it's already there and the
clock is set because you know it was in
fact a path that went differently or it
has this very structured property that
all cap shorter spots use X as the first
edge and in fact the pH of the spot is
just an extension by edge XA of the case
shorter Spartan P star a Y and that's
where the path extinction method comes
omote three minutes okay
they started late right yeah okay yeah
so anyway so and once we have this
observation but you still have to make
sure that the algorithm is correct there
are some technical details here but we
just create you know you can examine the
cue cue sets to it because you know it
takes us input the QK sets by examining
the Q key sets you can see which are the
problem pairs X Y and because the
problem pairs X Y or those for which the
K minus one shortest paths all start
with the same edge and for those you
know you potentially may need to extend
the tape shortest paths from NP star a Y
so you create that path and let's forget
about extensions you create that path
and what we do is we put it on a
priority queue because it may not be
correct at this point because even P
star a Y might be incorrect it might be
of the same form and you may need update
it but it turns out so we pre extend to
X and B place it in a priority queue
here's the entire algorithm it's a very
simple algorithm in the sense it just
uses a priority queue and you don't even
need a Dijkstra you don't even need a
Fibonacci heap a binary heaps of
surfaces and we can show that if you
just put these parts in there and do
this structured type of you know
extraction examination and deciding what
to do with the path that it will
correctly create the sets P star correct
sets P star and so if it's running time
is easily seen to be K and squared plus
N squared log N and so that gives or
tilde
MN for DSO and actually we get a
slightly faster algorithm we don't need
the full power of the air so there's a
very simple algorithm
give us this mn+ N squared log N and for
K equals three and in general for
general K the best method that we could
come up with was to recursively use the
K minus 1 ApS is P algorithm to compute
the QK sets and the problem with that as
we had to do that on all n vertices so
the running time increases by a factor
of n with each increase in K so it
becomes worthless after cake what's for
but at K equals 3 this already gives us
far faster by a linear buy at 8 of an
open factor over the best previous
algorithm and yeah so and okay so just
one comment so this is the second
algorithm that uses spot extensions this
is for finding that K enumerate in the
case shortest paths simple shortest
paths in the graph and you can see just
in here that it again that's part
extensions but it is completely it's a
different type of path succession a
different criterion for doing the path
extension and for example one difference
in terms of the invariance of the two
algorithms maintained is that in this
algorithm we guarantee that when we do
an extension and add it to the priority
queue again it has a priority queue it's
guaranteed to be simple in the previous
algorithm we could actually create add
to the priority queue apart with the
cycle it's only when we extract it that
we you know the criterion that we Esteve
we apply to whether or not we include it
guarantees that we would never add a
path with cycle okay so as I said it's
very efficient and somebody okay so Mary
so a may encounter the most novel
contribution here is that we've come up
with a new methodology for this
classical problem of finding multiple
simple shortest paths where all previous
methods use detours and now we are using
this path extension and very annoyingly
our current method I mean it because a
dramatic improvement for two ApS is P
basically gets the o tilde a man bound
it's also harmless or tilde MN and
pretty good for three it'll be great if
we could generalize it and perhaps
there's a different way of doing it that
would give us the QK sets
and we gave reductions and we you know
created the spasming wait cycle which
hopefully this community thinks is a
good hardness class and again and we
have a different very fast algorithm
okay or the SI SP and algorithmic e the
questions I think this is the question I
mean being used a recursive method to do
it now the QK sets are easier then
because it gives that it relaxes what we
need for the P star K sets so you're
computing something not as difficult as
the P star K sets maybe there is some
other way of constructing them that will
give us a better algorithm now space
usage is high in all our oil paste
algorithms so it will be nice if we can
obtain space efficient versions and
finally the hardness dispersement weight
cycle now in contrast to the n cubed sub
cubic hardness results where most of the
problems were reducible to one another
we here we are more like the I guess the
threesome situation we have the spasming
weight cycle and many other problems you
know which reduces to many other
problems so they are all you know at
least as hard as past minute cycle but
so far we have not closed close the you
know the reduction to give equivalence
so the one equivalence we had was
between KS is P and KS is C but in
general I think this is a very
interesting class to explore first
because in practice glasses drafts tend
to be sparse so it'll be good to get
good results and also it tends to be
more challenging as I think Emmanuel
viola said in gave a talk on the first
day where he talked about triangles
enumerated triangles and he the
challenges that come up when you go from
just the dense case the sparse case you
have to consider you know how the edges
get distributed if you had to solve
recursively so that's not so interesting
I think the questions to be addressed
been trying to you know to find this
class of specially-made cycle okay and
that's my talk
harden trying to show poisonous sort of
okay so well yeah I know but for many of
these problems for any constant K it was
you know Hotel de ml but there were a
few for which it was not the case let me
show you I mean pretty soon now here so
the ones for which we don't have yeah so
of course we have two and three but you
know okay two to three things I think we
don't I can't think of a natural
candidate from which to show this
conditional had cardless what above but
I actually think I mean now that this
hope all of you will work on finding the
two K sets more efficiently it's just
very annoying that right now I think
that perhaps K ApS is P can be brought
down you know I'm not convinced that
there is that lower but but yeah and
also I haven't thought about it and
there is this one and this one is just
it's just n applications of sis P yeah
so to answer your question no I haven't
thought about it and if you were going
to think about it it'll be interesting
to see you have to think of a sort of a
static problem that has resisted you
know sub M N squared or something for a
long time here I think min weight cycle
you know has certainly stood the test of
time and but that's a good question
so you know one-handed yes I think
because of just using distances it every
hour goes your work just implies thanks
for the dance case as well oh yeah all
of my work yeah okay oh four small ways
okay it took two comments here one is
that we have not been considering any
dependence on weights and I see it so
that's interesting because you know with
distance sensitive article with this if
you don't consider the edge weight size
we have a separate method that does it
faster than distance and City but yeah
but if you have a faster method for
distance density or occur for small
weights then that would be preferable to
our algorithm well that's cool yeah yeah
yeah so it's sub Amen oh no no no it's
no for dense graphs it would be n cubed
it so it is sub n cubed okay Oh
interesting
yeah okay thank you